- What does body positivity mean to you?
- You know, it's, it's interesting
'cause I feel like it's a term
that gets thrown around a lot
and it's sort of can be really simplified
and say like love yourself
and that's such a hard goal, you know?
And I think
body positivity to me is
exactly how we explore it
in Shrill, which is like
it's kind of this ongoing battle
and it's mostly internal.
It's like, how can you be
kinder to yourself and,
and be your own ally
as these external pressures come onto you.
And I, you know, it's
certainly changed my life
because I, I cut myself some slack
and stopped being so tough on myself
and also tried to stop that constant loop
inside your head of being like,
oh I shouldn't sit like
this or I shouldn't eat that
or I don't want someone to
see me with my double chin.
It's like, that's my reality
and I actually like myself
and
- Yeah.
- it just makes life a lot better.
(laughing)
- No, I agree.
I, I love that definition.
I have a very similar one.